i just got renamed myself
oh you did okay yeah i see that yeah
okay i was ian russell a second ago so
we're reading
i see that's still up there you're up
there twice okay gotcha
all right super again thank you for the
time and uh i know you're on a tight
schedule so if you don't mind we'll jump
right in
sure we're joined by governor
steve sisilak on eight news now governor
first of all let me just say thank you
for the time we do appreciate it it's an
honor pleasure to be with you and talk
to your viewers
governor it has been one year since the
uh first case of covet in nevada the
flags were flown at half staff the video
tribute put together by your office
in a year rife with challenges what was
the biggest one for you and your team
well i'm asked that question a lot you
know what was the biggest the hardest
uh we've come a long way in a year so
much has happened in one year you can't
even imagine when i got elected governor
the first year we did our business we
had a session
and we're getting into our uh proposals
in terms of funding education better and
health care and then
wham we got hit with a pandemic that
nobody ever expected the magnitude of
this
uh the decision early on
to close the schools and to shut down
the strip was extremely hard for me
i mean i consulted with all of my staff
all the scientists all the medical
examiners
and uh originally when we shut down the
schools if you remember it was only for
a couple weeks that we shut them down
and then it went on
but i remember the day that we meet i
finally made the decision to shut down
the strip las vegas boulevard i've told
this story i walked out on my balcony at
the grand sawyer building
and looked it downtown you could see it
it was just turning the nighttime and
you could see all the lights
on the strip and you can see all the
lights downtown and to think about
shutting that down meant that those
lights were all going to go out
and those people were all going to be
out of work was really really hard to do
because i knew the impact it was going
to have
the toll it was going to take on human
life the toll it was going to take on
people's finances and the ability to
support their
families uh and we did it and i know it
was the right thing to do
i'm glad we did it when we did uh but it
was difficult
it was really difficult it really when
you look down the strip in those days it
was almost eerie and think about each
and every one of those people as i know
you do when you look back at this year
what is something you are most proud of
and what is something
if you could get a do-over uh a mulligan
if you will
something you wish maybe a decision was
made slightly differently
as we kind of look in a retrospective
way yeah the
the thing that and before i get to that
i want to say when what you said is true
when i drove down this trip i had my
detail my security take me on a
trip down the strip one time to go to
work more than once
and to see the eeriness of nobody on the
strip and nobody open and
you know it was difficult the thing that
i am most proud of or i'm happiest about
is you saw the absolute best in people
through this pandemic and you saw the
worst in people through this pandemic
you had some folks that would not uh
chose not to comply with any of the
directives and didn't want to believe
that believe that coleman is a hoax
but at the same time you saw the best in
people you saw the nevada national guard
you saw them feeding people giving covet
tests
cleaning nursing homes uh giving covert
vaccines
delivering food delivering ppe they have
done
absolutely everything we've asked for
them all of the individuals that have
donated
whether it's food whether it's money
whether it's their time
to help a neighbor that was in need if
they knew they had a senior citizen
living next door
they couldn't get out to buy if you
remember at the very beginning you
couldn't get toilet paper
wipes they don't they they went and got
it and brought it to their neighbors
that weren't so fortunate
that was uh really heartwarming to see
how much people
uh sacrificed and did for other people
uh the difficult parts the two parts
were
one uh when you deal with families of
those who've lost a loved one
and you know that that person couldn't
get in to say goodbye
you know when the person was dying and
they counted on a nurse being with them
to hold their hand to face time with
their family that's how they got to say
goodbye
uh that was difficult that's extremely
difficult that people had to go through
that and couldn't have a
a proper goodbye to a loved one couldn't
have a proper burial
for a loved one and people made an awful
lot of sacrifices to that extent
governor a lot of good news lately in
terms of cases plummeting especially in
the past
six seven weeks sporting events coming
back
if you could clarify with the fact that
the governor's office for nascar weekend
and golden knights games put capacity at
20
and it seemed to be reduced to 15 from
southern nevada health
district we heard from bill foley and
chris powell
and their frustration with that wanting
the 20
that you talked about to be what happens
can you explain what exactly happened
there
sure i talked to bill uh who i'm a big
fan of both the golden knights and the
speedway has been a tremendous thing for
this community uh
we made a decision based on our medical
the medical advice i got our science
advice we got
a business in industry they looked at
all the plans all these venues that
they're going to put to people in
and i felt very very comfortable going
with 20
occupancy they could still be socially
distanced
uh they could still be safe i thought
for everybody involved
we made that uh part of a directive i
made that statement
and then the local jurisdictions whether
it's the
county or the city or the health
district said no we don't want to
give them 20 we only want to give them
15
i know there was a lot of frustration
with both chris and bill
as it related to that i understand their
frustration i know that they've had
people that have been waiting a year
to get into a race or to get into a
hockey game
and i understand that and uh like i said
i wanted 20
but the locals said that was they wanted
melt less so they ended up with less
governor more than half in a recent poll
supported your handling of the cobit
pandemic
over half were you uh as you look at the
43
that maybe did not how do you speak to
those that you're still trying to bring
on board
and what does it mean to you that over
have to approve of the job you've done
well i appreciate the fact that over
half approve of the job that we've done
it's not me it's
i've got to assemble the great team i
mean whether it's my staff here in
carson city with me or
where's the doctors and the medical
professionals our covenant task force
uh our prophet advisory committee that
rolls out all this stuff
we're taking the best information we can
and moving forward
for the people that uh don't support
what i'm doing or how we're doing it
i understand that i still represent you
i still want to do the best i possibly
can
but some people just are i understand
that they
most people think you should wear a mask
but they don't want to be told where i'm
asking
and i get that but i'm telling you it
works it makes a big big difference i
wish people would look at it
uh from the point of view if you don't
wear the master yourself as much as you
wear it for the people that you love
and the people you care about the people
you live with the people you work with
uh
people you live near you know your
family members and i would encourage
everybody to please do your part now is
not the time to let up and take your
foot off the gas so to speak
uh now is the time to double down and
continue as we get more and more people
vaccinated every day
we get thousands of more people of
accident we have thousands of shots in
people's arms so every day it's getting
a little bit better
yeah then we need to hold on for a
couple more
months in order to get get where we can
get to that immunity of 80 to 90
then we'll be in great shape yeah the
news continues to get brighter well put
and you aptly pointed out the
individuals the people that have lost
their jobs and talk about
the 295 000 cases in nevada we talk
about the over 5 000 that have died
the individuals that have lost their
jobs they're struggling with a
way of life that is due to them a lot of
issues with dieter
you've talked a lot about this how do
you explain what
went wrong at times with dieter and are
we turning the corner
yeah and that's a great question i
appreciate the chance to address that
dieter is in a difficult situation we
had a system that was set up
that when we originally shut everything
down and we're in the thrones that froze
with the pandemic
our claims to dieter were 25 times what
they normally were
instead of getting 12 000 in a week we
had 300
000 claims in a week i mean no system
is set up to handle that kind of a
volume
uh the past legislatures have not
invested
into a new computer system technology
for deter which is unfortunate i wish
they would have they have not staffed it
up
the way they should have at the same
time you can't staff it up for 300 000
claims a week
when you're only getting 12 000 clams a
week or everybody be sitting around and
we'd be paying them to do nothing
so that wouldn't work that was a problem
the system was not set up to handle this
and hopefully we will learn as we move
forward so we'll get it better
also the biggest problem i've talked to
our director today
we have 500 000 claims for uh d for ui
or a pua uh
and they are estimating 95
of us 95 are fraudulent
five percent of them are legitimate so
what happens
not only are you hurting the state and
the businesses
because these small businesses that
exist are going to have to the money
that we spent they've got to put back
into the deter uh trust fund you need to
get more money in there for so we can
continue the program going
and they've clogged up the system so
much
uh with these fake claims and phony
claims
that it's really impacted legitimate
claimants so
i'm talking to my staff i think it's
important we do something about this and
this isn't 475 000
different people that put in claims this
is a group of syndicated
whatever you want to call it the that
are putting in tens of thousands of
claims
and getting all these cards and getting
the benefits
and i think we need to take a bolder
step in terms of
investigating and prosecuting the
perpetrators of that because
they continue to put in fraudulent
claims they're not questionable where
you don't know
if you should get it you shouldn't get
it these are people putting claims that
have no rights to it
they're putting in multiple claims under
different names stealing identities
it's just a really sad situation 95
fraudulent question about vaccinations
uh we are getting a lot of shots in arms
in nevada
we did find out that nevada's vaccine
allocation rate was using 24 to
2014 to 2018 census estimates which was
impacting the numbers
are you happy with the vaccination
process as of now and what do you want
to see different to improve it
well i'm happy but i can always be
happier we have a weekly call
the governor's association does with the
president's task force on vaccines every
week i look forward to the call because
every week they've upped our allocation
you know we're getting more and more and
more
it's unfortunate that they're using old
population estimates which
which kind of got us this is it's
hurting the states that are getting more
people moving and it's helping the
states that people are moving out of
so that's a problem for that uh what i
want to see happen
and we're going to continue to expand
our sites
that are going to be made available to
go get vaccines
i want to see more and more of our
elderly population
get the vaccine my mom's 94 she got both
of hers so i'm thrilled with that
she can feel safer but we need to get
our senior citizens vaccinated
and we need to do more in our minority
communities and we're gonna we're gonna
get into those communities our
are black and brown communities where
there's a little more hesitancy to get
the vaccine
but i want to open these up and give out
every single dose that we can possibly
get coming our way
and uh i think we're going to continue
to do that right now you've got
this many vaccines and this many people
want the vaccine
but it's slowly starting to change when
we're going to have this many vaccines
and to wait out here
people are going to be willing to get
them so we need to continue to educate
people
to encourage them to go out and get the
vaccine and the first chance you get
to get an appointment get a vaccine i
don't care which one it is
if it's a needle with a vaccine they're
putting in your arm go get it we're all
going to be better off as a result
governor we appreciate your time glad to
hear your mom 94 years old got the
vaccines is doing well
and thank you so much for making time
for us here on eight news now we do
appreciate it
appreciate it thank you i know she
watches news so she'll probably hear
this
hello the governor's mom there you go
thank you all right